[Music]
you all remember zoe saldana in the 2002
cult classic crossroads right well now
we know for sure it was her co-star
Britney Spears that actually spilled the
beans about Zoe's pregnancy back in 2014
she's pregnant with twins right now
Zoe was asked about the situation on
Thursdays watch what happens live with
Andy Cohen
she has two boys I was having twins we
had a beautiful talk and I forgot it
never even occurred to me to tell her
not to say anything I was shocked
because we weren't ready to sort of
share that but it was Britney so it was
okay let's go Britney and Zoe's
friendship is the stuff dreams are made
of
Zoe defended Britt's honor on the same
show in 2014 I have a huge amount of
respect for Britney Spears people and
children gravitate to good energy and
she she's definitely in abundance of
that and Brittany told ET she'd love to
collaborate again was there any chance
that you two talked about maybe possibly
doing a movie again together um who
knows that's a very good idea idea
[Music]
you